so now it's like i could do whatever i
want you know i could put out a
christmas album and that's why i like
the christmas album the most because
it's the most fun it's the first time i
sat down i really had fun yeah and felt
like i was a kid again in a studio and i
i had a blast all the songs go together
so if you could look at it like a movie
but oh that's what we were talking about
we were talking about how it [ __ ] up
let me tell you how this delivery [ __ ]
up so a christmas album you really only
have a certain window right
so the guy who shot videos for me
caught coved on the way back so the
first week when the videos were coming
out he couldn't get him out
so the videos are three weeks late you
know what i'm saying are two weeks late
so i mean you only got two more weeks
before christmas is over
so you know that [ __ ] was weird that
[ __ ] [ __ ] me up the timing did you
think about just holding off until next
christmas to drop it no [ __ ] no my
personal life was going through a
[ __ ] downfall funnel goddamn cake at
the same time so it was like it was just
a big whirlwind of fuckness
but um yeah if if uh but yeah we're
gonna keep i i personally think like for
me the christmas album is the best body
of work i've ever made my whole life and
i've been rapping since nineteen ninety
two ritzmas
ritzmas
and chris and of course chris was saying
for everybody nobody get you know what
i'm saying but it's a good um